(chill hip hop beat)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing show,
the number one podcast for
growing and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell,
and we're from Think Media.
And if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show's dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed
and the latest money-making strategies
working right now online.
So whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
So it's 2020.
Is it too late to start a YouTube channel?
- Yeah, that question is
more relevant now than ever
because on the one hand
YouTube is 15 years old now.
I mean, it started in 2005.
And so of course competition is rising,
the platform is maturing.
There's even been some
new drama on YouTube
with COPPA and things like that.
But on the other hand my
answer is still absolutely not.
It is not too late to start.
It is still
even the early stages of the
internet and social media.
And I think the fact is
we're still seeing people
rise, build channels.
Yes, there's new challenges,
but there's also new
opportunities every single day.
So I'd say no it's not too late to start
if you've got the right
tips and strategies.
- So a lot of people that
come onto the platform
think that you need to vlog your life,
you want to just create general content.
Do you have some examples
of people who are crushing
it right now on YouTube?
- Yeah, not only some examples
of people crushing it,
but I actually did some research
of some people who only
started in the last year or so.
And so I looked up Dr. iHealth,
he's a part of our video
ranking academy community.
He's about a year in,
he's uploading five videos a month,
he's at 80,000 subscribers,
he's getting 23,000 views a month and,
or 1.2 million views a month,
growing by 23,000 subscribers.
It's crazy, his channel's blowing up.
And he's an eye doctor.
And I think what we learn from that
is that he's in a niche
of actually helping people
with what's wrong with my eye
or colored contact lenses.
He's doing something specific.
Another example is Vanessa Lou.
We actually interviewed her
over on our channel video "Influencers".
She's doing four videos a month,
11,000 new subscribers a month.
She's only one year into YouTube.
She has niched down in a couple ways.
She helps people with social media advice
but specifically millennials.
And even probably more millennial females.
So niching down,
starting in just the last year.
Now you can't really reference people
that have started in the last week or so,
'cause it takes time to grow on YouTube.
But people are crushing it in the now era
with today's challenges.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference
Grow With Video Live.
A $1,500 value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple Podcast,
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
You may have seen,
or people may have seen Donya Angelo.
She's this really sweet
Mexican grandmother
who lives on a ranch in Mexico
and wanted to just make
some authentic recipes.
And in just a few months,
she is almost to two million subscribers.
She's uploading a lot of videos.
She's actually uploading
about eight videos a month.
22 million views a month,
growing by 350,000 subscribers a month.
Which just kind of shows us
that it doesn't matter where you live,
doesn't matter what age you are.
It was actually her
daughter that had the idea,
that said "What if we put
your cooking on YouTube?"
And so I think that these are
the types of illustrations,
Roger Wakefield, the expert plumber.
He's a residential service provider
that is early stage in YouTube.
He's about a year in.
He's uploading a lot of videos,
15 videos a month.
But he's growing by 3,100
subscribers a month.
He's almost to 20,000 subscribers.
So I think all of these
examples are just showing us
no matter what age you
are, ethnicity, background,
whether you're using YouTube for business,
for social media advice,
that the opportunity,
it's just still happening.
There really is no excuses.
You can complain about it being crowded
or complain about challenges,
but all those excuses are being destroyed
by the examples of people
that are just taking action,
putting in the hustle,
and being intelligent with their strategy.
- And now there has been
a lot of drama wrapped around YouTube.
60 Minutes just did a full expo on them.
And there's a lot happening.
Is it still a platform that you,
I know you love YouTube.
But is it platform that you
still think is alive and well?
- Yeah, I think so, absolutely,
because at the same while
there's increasing drama,
which I think that's just
the progression of anything.
I mean it's like we want to have
success without conflict.
But there is never going to be
anything great done without challenges.
It's an uphill battle.
Everything worthwhile is uphill.
And so yeah, there's challenges.
But also there's now
over two billion monthly
active users on YouTube.
YouTube TV is alive and well.
I was just having lunch in Las Vegas
'cause my brother's out here
for the Amazon conference.
And he was talking about
how him and his wife
only use YouTube TV now.
They've cut the cord everywhere else.
So YouTube as a company
is the most viewed video platform online,
it's the second most
visited website online,
it's the second largest
search engine in the world.
So it's like what are we talking about?
There's so much opportunity there.
All the eyeballs are there.
So yeah, I mean, it's
still alive and well.
I think if you're creating kids content,
but we're also gonna see
the evolution of that,
there are so challenges with COPPA.
For everybody else,
for anybody who's not
targeting anybody under age 13,
you should really still dive into YouTube
because I think it's gonna
be an incredible year.
But even a next incredible
decade in YouTube's life.
- And so what do you
think are some mistakes,
there's key mistakes that people make
when they get started on the platform?
- Yeah, I mean I think when
you're starting on YouTube,
some of the biggest mistakes
is starting without a plan.
It's kind of true with anything.
If you fail to plan you plan to fail.
I think the other mistake that people make
is there is there is
myth about social media
that it's kind of like this magic pill.
And that's what we all want.
We might be up late night,
we're watching some infomercials,
and we see this electrode machine
that's like "You want six pack abs?
"All you got to do is
connect these electrodes,
"sit and what TV, eat
Cheetos and turn it on,
"and it'll zap you into a six pack."
Well, that doesn't work.
You actually have to
change the way you eat,
start exercising to change your physique.
If you want to crush on YouTube,
you actually have to invest in YouTube.
I think it's shifting
your mindset from dabbling
and going into really
dominating and saying
I'm gonna treat this serious,
I'm gonna treat this like a real business.
And business is competitive.
All the businesses,
all the coffee shops
in Las Vegas right now
where we're recording this,
they're not just rolling over
and thinking that if our coffee sucks
or if we only open a couple days a week
and we're not consistent with our hours,
and if our service is inconsistent,
oh yeah, we're entitled to success.
No, you would never
think that in business.
But people approach social media, YouTube,
sometimes with that mentality.
I'll upload whenever.
I'm lobbing out a video.
Why am I not growing?
Just kind of with this
half-hearted approach.
No, you got to stop dabbling
and start dominating.
And I think when you put that
energy and that focus into it,
that's where the magic happens.
- Yeah, and we started this out saying
YouTube is now 15 years old.
And that comes with different complexities
of how you were to start on YouTube.
So what is your strategy?
What do you have that is I'm starting now
15 years into this platform,
what do you suggest?
- Yeah, I mean I think that
probably the best thing I'd recommend
is we can link to a playlist
of some of our best strategy videos.
And that is the thing.
I like that you used the word "strategy",
because we've said this a
lot in our Think community.
That when you started on YouTube
it was okay if you were playing checkers.
A fun game,
a hard game because you
got to get down the board,
you want to get your queen
so you can start dominating.
But you only have one style of pieces
that eventually change into really two.
And it's a little simpler.
Well you compare checkers to chess.
You've got pawns, knights, rooks.
You've got the king and the queen.
There's so many different moves,
so many different aspects to strategy.
And you hear chess related
to a lot of things.
Related to politics, you
got to be playing chess.
To business, you got to be playing chess.
Why?
Because you need to be
thinking multi-dimensionally.
You need to be thinking in 4D.
People are saying you're playing 4D chess.
I think that's the secret
to YouTube right now.
It's saying no, I need a real strategy,
a real approach to this.
I can't just,
yes, you got to punch fear
in the face and press record.
But you need a plan on paper,
you need to really think
about what your end goal is,
think about your content schedule,
think about how you're tying into trends
and those types of things.
And we don't have enough
time to go into that here.
So I would say definitely
check out that playlist
of videos that we have on that content
and stop playing checkers
and start playing chess
if you want to win in 2020 and beyond.
- Thanks for checking out this episode.
We hope you got a tone of value.
And if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the Think Marketing show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple Podcast.
- As we grow this movement
of purpose-driven content creators,
we encourage you to share it with a friend
and we'll see you in the next episode.
(chill hip hop beat)